jones yeah i'm here
all right can you see my screen yep all
right
welcome welcome nicholas andrew jones
from perimeter institute and
uh stanford um
yeah and whenever you're ready yeah sure
um
okay yeah so i'd like to start by
thanking the organizers for
putting together this great workshop and
for letting me speak and of course all
of you for
uh for listening and please feel free to
interrupt with questions
at any point throughout the talk
something's unclear
so today i'll be talking about some
applications of ideas in quantum many
body physics and statistical mechanics
to some problems in quantum information
and this is based on a few different
papers one from
two years ago and uh one more recently
from this past december which was joint
work with jonas haferkom
who i think you'll hear from later this
week and uh both of these we kind of
studied a notion of
pseudorandomness and use various
techniques to to show that random
circuits are
in some sense uh random which i'll
define more precisely later
and if i have if i have time at the end
of the talk
i might also mention uh some additional
work uh which was joined with alex
desell and fernando
brandow who were at caltech and aws
on um on additional properties that
random circuits satisfy
okay so the very broad takeaway from
this talk is just that ideas from
statistical mechanics and quantum many
body physics are
incredibly useful for solving what i see
as fundamental problems in quantum
information theory
and uh specifically i want to talk about
random quantum circuits and these are
very interesting models for both
quantum many body physicists as well as
quantum information theorists
because they're efficient
implementations of randomness and are
also a rare instance of a solvable model
of chaotic dynamics
so in the latter sense uh rqcs are
valuable
uh or sorry in the former sense because
they're uh their valuable resource and
quantum information
because they're essentially optimal
decouplers they rapidly scramble
uh quant and delocalized quantum
information
their low depth implementations of
unitary designs and
as we heard about in the previous talk
the hardness of sampling the
from the output distribution of random
circuits means that they're good
candidates for demonstrating quantum
advantage such as in the recent google
supremacy experiments
um if you're more of a quantum mini body
physicist
you like random circuits because they're
you know a rare instance of a model
where you can kind of directly
analyze otherwise intractable quantities
and study things like
thermalization the onset of chaotic
dynamics
and even things like transport from
diffusive hydrodynamics
okay so more specifically the model i
want to consider today are local random
quantum circuits
on a system of n units of local
dimension q
and the evolution i want to consider is
uh this
brick brickwork pattern of staggered
layers of two site unitaries
where we'll act on even links at even
time steps and odd links at odd time
steps
and for simplicity i'm going to draw
each gate randomly
in both space and time so every gate is
drawn randomly
from the unitary group on two sites um
and where evolution to time t is a depth
t unitary which is given as the product
of t
layers okay um
and yeah so for simplicity i'll sort of
focus on these 1d
circuits uh on these local uh circuits
well no 1d chain of qubits
but we could also consider circuits to
find on some
arbitrary graph or in higher dimensions
or even a complete graph
and we could also consider circuits
where instead of drawing a
heart like these local gates
horrendously we draw them from some
universal gate set
and if sort of like a lot of the results
i'm going to say do generalize to those
cases so feel free to ask
about those cases or what might change
uh you know what kind of scalings might
change if you're interested in a
particular model um
right so as i was mentioning uh random
circuits have appeared in a number of
different archive categories
and um on the more convinced matter side
they've been used to study chaotic
dynamics and there are all these
interesting questions
uh related to surface growth problems
and
specifically the entanglement or
operator growth
exhibits kpz universality in the front
dynamics and there are some nice
connections to
growth problems and polymers and random
media
rqc's with conserved charges have been
used to study diffusive hydrodynamics
and one can also consider random
circuits with interspersed measurements
throughout the circuit and study a
volume lot of area law phase transition
and as i as i mentioned random circuit
sampling
is kind of a this underlies uh you know
google's claim of quantum supremacy and
i'll i'll get back to that at the end of
the talk
okay so a lot of these properties these
interesting properties i mentioned can
be seen as arising from uh one
particular
property possessed by random circuits
and that's their ability to rapidly
generate quantum pseudorandomness
and more specifically what i mean is uh
i want to study the convergence of
random unitary circuits to
unitary k designs so this is the circuit
depth t where we start approximating
moments of the unitary group
okay and just so all of my parameters
all the parameters in the talk appear on
one slide
i'm going to be considering systems of n
qudits okay where the local dimension is
q
it'll turn out to be a useful parameter
to play with um
such that the total hilbert space
dimension is q to the n
and total hyperspace is going to be d uh
again depth t circuits so it's t layers
and uh i'm going to be interested in in
in the case moment of the unitary group
so those are
there should be all the parameters in
the talk um are there any questions
about the setup before i start
defining things more precisely
okay and if questions appear in the chat
if someone could just read them out to
me i'd appreciate it
okay so i'll start by defining what a
unitary design is
and then give sort of two proofs that
random circuits form unitary designs
using different ideas from
uh from many body physics and
uh then we'll kind of move past designs
in the last few minutes of the talk and
and look at a
another quantity called
anti-concentration
okay so recall that the har measure is
the unique
left and right invariant measure on the
unitary group
and for some ensemble of unitaries
uh we're often interested in in moments
of that ensemble
and those moments are are sort of
captured by an object called the k-fold
channel
of an operator and that's defined for
an ensemble of unitaries is this sort of
average over the ensemble
right of the of the cave moment
and we're often interested in when some
ensemble of unitaries looks
like uh you know looks har random and
that'll be our notion of
pseudo-randomness in the stock
and what we'll say is that we'll say
that an ensemble of unitaries
is an exact k design if these k-fold
channels are equal for all operators o
right so the ensembles are equal up to
the k-th moment
okay so for k equals one powlies or any
basis of operators forms an exact one
design
um but for general k very little is
known
very few exact constructions are known
so to make progress we can relax our
definitions and instead of asking when
we exactly capture
the k-th moment of the har measure we
can instead ask when an ensemble looks
close to harm
more precisely we'll say that an
approximate k design is an ensemble for
which
the k-fold channels are close in diamond
norm
okay and designs are very useful
notion in quantum information because
they sort of allow you to wield the
power
the full power of the unitary group with
relatively low complexity
and just a little bit a little bit more
intuition
maybe with some pictures uh what we're
saying is an ensemble
of unitaries so you should picture this
you know this full this big unitary
group here
and we might have some ensemble of
unitaries that's some splattering of
points
all over the unitary group and what
we're saying is when we average over
that set of points
right up to the kth moment so maybe of
of some polynomial or monomial of
ku's and ku daggers uh we're saying that
that average
that average over that set of points is
extremely close to the average over the
full unitary group
again up to the case moment
and maybe maybe one more piece of
intuition we can sort of think about
this as asking
how random the time evolution of a
system is compared to the full unitary
group
right so in this setup we consider an
ensemble of time evolutions at a fixed
time t
so these could be could be random
quantum circuits
these things called brownian circuits or
even some ensemble of time independent
hamiltonian evolutions
uh generated by an ensemble of
disordered hamiltonians so you know
pick your favorite spin system into sort
of the couplings okay
at time equals zero this is just a bunch
of points sitting at the identity
but chaotic time evolution is going to
move us rapidly and ergotically over the
unitary group
and we can quantify how random that time
evolution is by asking
you know what time t do we form a k
design
and start approximating you know
capturing moments of the unitary group
of the heart measure there's a question
why the diamond norm
oh yeah that's a very fair question um
it's sort of
i'm just going to choose that for the
sake of you know convenience
uh in this talk there are definitely
lots of other definitions
and even for various so sort of the
definition of the design you want to use
might depend on the application you have
in mind
and oftentimes that you know so this is
sort of some uh
additive error and oftentimes you might
want a relative error which requires
kind of driving this epsilon down to be
exponentially small
but sort of for everything i'm going to
say in the talk it's not actually going
to really matter
so if if you want a relative notion of
design
you can just take this epsilon to be
exponentially small and that's actually
going to be fine for everything i say
so it's just sort of for convenience
later in the talk given how i'm going to
actually bound things
but um yeah if you have another
definition of of design that you like
um everything i say will also hold so
you'll be able to bound bound your
favorite definition with the diamond
norm
does that answer the question well let
me know if there's a follow-up
to that
okay um good
so actually quite a bit is known about
this question of random circuits forming
designs
uh and famously brenda o'hara and
hordetsky showed in 2012 that uh
1d random quantum circuits form
approximate designs
in a depth which scales linearly in n
and uh this high degree polynomial in k
okay um and
yeah they used some a beautiful set of
techniques uh which maybe we'll mention
in a little bit but they were also able
to show
a uh they also established a lower bound
on the design depth
and um argued that for for 1d circuits
had to be linear in n and linear in k
so there's sort of some lore in the
community for a number of years that uh
random quantum circuits saturate this
lower bound and form approximate designs
in this optimal depth linear in n and
linear in k
okay um and i'll get back to this in a
second but
uh uh there are a few other results
which i think are really nice which i'll
just briefly mention
uh more recently uh harrow and meriben
showed
extended extended this result to random
quantum circuits defined on a
d-dimensional
uh graph and and showed that basically
higher dimensional random circuits form
designs
again in a sublinear scaling in n but
some high degree polynomial k
in depth scales that way um and much
more recently uh
these two groups from germany showed
that um random clifford circuits
with kind of uh a polynomial number of
non-clifford gates
uh scattered throughout the circuit uh
form designs and a depth which scales
linearly in n and pollen some high
degree polynomial in k
uh you know at least up to the first few
moments
and uh yeah this uh yeah and the sca and
the number of non-clifford gates you
needed only scaled uh
you know polynomial in k but independent
of n
okay so i should emphasize that designs
are incredibly useful they sort of pop
up in
every sub-area of bottom information
that i'm familiar with you know from
state distinguishability tomography
um randomized benchmarking or you know
the different sorts of physics
applications like thermalization
or fast information scrambling
and while many of these results only
require maybe two or four designs
high degree designs are often essential
for arguments about concentration
so saying that a single instance or a
single random circuit or a single
instance of your ensemble you know
is actually extremely close to the to
the average
and um high degree designs are also
useful in understanding some long-time
properties
uh of of systems past equilibration
so to just give two examples of what i
mean by that
you could consider some initial state
evolved by an element
acted on by an element of a unitary k
design and you could ask uh
how close the subsystem and the entropy
of some subsystem is
to its thermal value to its equilibrium
value
and what you can prove is that the
probability that that subsystem entropy
deviates
from its equilibrium value is
exponentially suppressed in the total
hybrid space dimension by powers of k
okay so if you know that you have some
time evolving system
and you know that that time evolving
system is forming designs as
it evolves then what you can show is
that the
uh fluctuations of subsystem entropies
you know
continue to get rarer and rarer in time
and keep getting suppressed by
additional powers
of of the total hoverspace dimension um
uh all the way up to potentially
exponential times
so sort of what this is saying is and
you know one one thing you can use
uh designs to prove is that maybe
subsystems of many body systems are a
lot more static than you might have
thought um
and another uh another uh use of designs
and understanding the post
equilibration properties of many body
systems is in understanding the growth
of quantum complexity
so um by here here i i'm referring to
the circuit complexity
which is the minimal circuit required to
implement approximately
prepare or implement your unitary and
you can show that the complexity of a
element from a design
scales linearly in k so if you're then
able to prove that your
your time evolution generates designs as
it grows in time as you as your time
evolve then you can
prove that you know some lower bound on
the complexity growth
okay so you know this uh this brenda
harrow horizon result i mentioned gives
us uh
gives a lower bound which is the slow
slow growth in time
but if you're able to prove a linear
growth in design
you would then establish a conjecture of
linear growth of complexity
where it's been conjectured that most
local random quantum circuits of depth t
have a complexity which scales linearly
in time for an exponentially long time
okay so these are just sort of two
examples of where you know
high degree designs are interesting from
like a physics point of view
understanding many body systems
okay so to get back to designs um
we want to study the circuit depth at
which random quantum circuits start
forming designs and i'm just going to
sort of briefly present two theorems um
using different ideas from
quantum many body physics and
statistical mechanics which
establish this optimal behavior or
almost optimal behavior
so this linear scaling in n and k
if you allow yourself to play with the
local dimension
okay um
and the two approaches i'm going to use
to compute the design depth foreign
quantum circuits involve
upper bounding the partition function of
a lattice model and lower bounding the
spectral gap of a local hamiltonian
so before i get into the into the uh
main content of the talk i'll just pause
for questions are there any questions
about anything i've said or what the
setup is or
or why i'm interested in what i'm doing
all right so more questions again feel
free to write them into the chat
so um i'll just focus on the first
approach
and recall i defined a unitary design in
terms of this diamond norm
but diamond norms are famously famously
hard to compute
so we're going to take a retreat to a
more tractable
notion of our randomness and to do this
i'm going to consider the k
moment of opera case moment operators
for the ensemble of unitaries
which is given by this this uh this
object here
and this allows us to define a more
tractable notion of our randomness
because we can consider the
the two-norm distance between the moment
operator the k-th moment operator
of the ensemble we're interested in and
the har ensemble
and this two norm can be conveniently
written in terms of something called the
case frame potential for the ensemble
okay so this frame potential is just
defined as this uh
this sort of double average over over
all the inner products of your
of your design elements and
for an ensemble of unitaries the k frame
potential is lower bounded
by k factorial with equality if and only
if you form a
exact k design okay
so what this is saying is if you hand me
uh some ensembles of unitaries
you can compute this frame potential for
a given k and how close
and you'll get some number and how close
that number is to k
factorial tells you how close you are to
forming a design
in into normal distance okay and then
you know i defined designs in terms of
this diamond norm so we'll need to
basically we'll be able to upper bound
the diamond norm using this weaker
weaker norm just by showing basically
that this distance is uh
this difference is exponentially small
okay so the goal now is to compute this
frame potential for random quantum
circuits evolve to time
t right so the ensemble we're interested
in is depth t random quantum circuits
and to compute this quantity basically
this is just moments of traces
of random quantum circuits we
it's a some k-th moment quantity so we
need to do some k-th moment average of
random quantum circuits for which we
need to consider k
copies of the circuit and its conjugate
and
in in performing this average we're just
basically averaging over all these two
site unitaries
and if if you recall you can kind of
understand
averaging these gates uh you know doing
these local averages
as uh as a basically our averaging is
sort of a prescription for index
contraction
so there's a way to rewrite these uh
these averages over the two site
unitaries
in terms of a way like a way to keep
track of all these uh
index contractions and you can
and you can write these local averages
as uh as some
as some uh effective plaquette term um
and what that allows you to do is define
the spring potential or rewrite this
frame potential
as the partition function on a
triangular lattice model
okay so i'm skipping over a lot of
details but basically uh
you know when you do this average
there's some massive index contractions
which that however tells you you need to
sum over and with
given weights and the uh and basically
those contractions are you're
contracting these indices with respect
to some element of the
of the symmetric group sk and you're
keep and we're just keeping track of all
those with uh with basically
some some uh some nice tensor network
diagrams where the local degrees of or
some nice lattice model where the local
degrees of freedom are
uh elements of the symmetric group and
uh you know
these uh these lines uh encode the
weight of a given
given contraction roughly speaking but
the end result is that this frame
potential can be
exactly written as the partition
function on a on a lattice model
where this lattice model has width n
over two depth to t and with periodic
boundary conditions in time
so all these nodes here are identified
with all these nodes up here
and the local degrees of freedom are
again elements of sk
and the weight of a given spin
configuration is given by the product of
plaquette terms
and a given plaquette term is a function
of three spins which is just
uh can be exactly written as this
function this function here but it's not
too important what this is it's just
some function we can compute
and then you know it's a partition
function in the sense that we we sum
over all
overall spin configurations you know
with weights determined
determined as i just said
all right so the first thing you can
show is that by plugging in the same
spin everywhere
by plugging in the same spin everywhere
on this lattice you have a weight one
and thus we can already see where this
minimal r value comes from so i told you
that the spring potential is lower
bounded by k factorial
and this value comes from the k
factorial ground states
of the lattice model right so there are
k factorial ways we can plug in the same
spin everywhere
so the data horrendousness must come
from the decreasing contribution of all
the excited term excited states
higher order terms in this partition
function
right and kind of trivially if you plug
in
well yeah for the first moment there's
only you know
one way to plug in the same spin
everywhere so there's just one
configuration
for the first frame potential so the
frame potential is just one um
and random quantum circuits form exact
one design
but the second moment is non-trivial um
and they're all non-zero contributions
to this partition function our domain
walls
can be thought about as domain walls in
the lattice model which must which must
wrap the circuit so for the second
moment
here's an example of a single domain
wall configuration or a double domain
wall configuration
so this is for the second moment where
the local degrees of freedom are
elements of
the symmetric group s2 so we have you
know some region of identities and
regions some region of swaps and you
know
we can think about that spin
configuration in terms of the domain
while separating the regions of
identities and swaps
so to compute the second frame potential
to understand uh how you know the
convergence to approximate two designs
um we just simply need to count all the
possible domain wall configurations
um so sort of for for general k you
always have k factorial ground states
then you can sort of think about the
single domain wall configurations the
double domain wall configurations
and it's just some some messy
combinatorial procedure to sort of
compute or bound
those possible contributions but we see
that the decay of our randomness comes
from the
sort of stretching of the domain walls
as we evolve the circuit right so as we
evolve in time these circuits get deeper
and deeper
these domain walls you can think about
them as basically stretching thus
contributing higher energy and lower
partition weight
to the uh to the sum
okay so for the for the second frame
potential
uh kind of upper bounding all these
terms is pretty straightforward
and what you find is this um and that
allows you to directly compute the
circuit depth where you form an
approximate two design
it's basically just uh n plus log one
over epsilon
or more precisely uh it's this sort of
the bound on the two design depth is
this with some exact determination of
the coefficients
okay um uh and
it's maybe fun just to mention that you
can actually compute the k equals two
partition function exactly
without having to kind of upper bound
the mineral configurations by solving
the problem of p
non-intersecting random walkers on a
line and that makes use of some nice
statistical physics ideas from the 80s
but for our purposes all we need is the
upper bound
um and for general k this same picture
holds
but we sort of the picture for k equals
two is a lot simpler because you just
have one
type of domain wall and it's pretty
straightforward to bound all the domain
wall configurations
and compute this partition function but
for general k
uh there are a lot more types of domain
walls it turns out
and they're allowed to interact pair
create and annihilate and
um this basically means the
combinatorics of domain while counting
are a lot less amenable to a precise
treatment
but there are two things you can prove
or a few things you can prove which
which allow you to say something useful
so for general k
as i said you always know that you have
this contribution from the ground state
so basically always know that there are
k factorial ground states of weight one
and you can also exactly compute the
contribution from the single domain wall
terms
and you just find this this expression
here
um and it's sort of the higher order
terms that are that are a mess to uh
to bound but what you can further prove
is that all higher order terms uh which
are
multi-domain wall terms are heavily
suppressed and necessarily must be
subleading and one over q
so there's they're suppressed
additionally suppressed by powers of the
local dimension q
and what that allows you to show is that
for some local dimension
which you know some for some large value
of the local dimension
this sector of single domain wall terms
needs to dominate
and you know you just do the calculation
and you find from the single domain role
sector
the design depth is is this optimal
value which is
linear in n k
so uh just to reiterate um what we've
shown
um uh using this uh using this two norm
approach
is that random quantum circuits on n
qudits form approximate k designs
when the depth is uh is uh is at least
linear in n and k
for some large value of the local
dimension um
and again this is you know a rigorous
statement
and large q but there are a number of
reasons why i think this uh
this limit of large local dimensions is
not necessary um so i just sort of left
it as a conjecture that
for for any local dimension q the single
domain wall sector
of this lattice partition function needs
to bound the basically higher order
terms
so the higher order terms are basically
conjecturing they're small for
you know even q equals two um
but uh as the lower bound on the design
depth uh is linear in n and k
uh what we've then shown is that random
quantum circuits are then optimal
implementations of this notion of
pseudorandomness
at least in this limit of large local
dimension
so that was the that was the first
approach to showing that random quantum
circuits form designs
are there any questions about uh about
this method
or this approach
pause for a few seconds
okay so the second approach i want to
talk about
is uh involves lower bounding the
spectral gap
and um this again involves a retreat to
a different note
uh a different notion of design so
instead we're going to focus on the
operator norm
difference of these moment operators and
for depth c random quantum circuits
these this operator norm has two very
nice properties
so the first is amplification so what
this says is that um you know we have to
look at this operative norm difference
of the moment operators for
uh the ensemble of random quantum
circuits and uh horror ensemble
um but uh you don't actually need to
consider this
this uh this uh you know basically full
depth t
uh random quantum circuits just sort of
every time you act with another layer
this operator norm just gets amplified
by some power t
okay so you don't actually need to
consider the you know full depth random
quantum circuits we just sort of need to
consider
this action of a single layer or the the
moment operator for a single layer
um and then the second nice property is
that the uh
this uh this operator norm for the
moment operator of a single layer can be
reinterpreted as the
gap of a local hamiltonian so we can
bound this uh difference
uh by by the gap of some local
hamiltonian
where you should sort of think about
these these local terms as the
as the local moment operators for the
for the gates themselves
so they should sort of think about the
terms of the hamiltonian as like the uh
you know as like a sum over the sort of
operator the projection operators which
are
themselves the uh uh the gates in the
random quantum circuit
um so as you can see here if
if you compute this spectral gap and you
show that it's zero
right then this here this uh this upper
normal is just less than one
and if we amplify one we don't learn
anything so we need some sort of
non-trivial lower bound on the spectral
gap of this hamiltonian
to get convert to get uh you know to
have some useful amplification as we
evolve in time
uh which will then give us some
convergence to uh to a
k design okay so we need to some
non-trivial lower bound on this
uh on the spectral gap of this
hamiltonian
so there are a few nice properties that
this hamiltonian possesses um
it's the sum of projectors well yeah the
hamiltonian is a sum of projectors it
has ground state energy zero
and it is uh frustration free so i think
norbert mentioned
frustration free hamiltonians briefly in
his talk uh two talks ago
but uh just to reiterate um a
frustration free hamiltonian is one
where the
ground state of the hamiltonian is also
the ground state
of uh of uh of each term in the
hamiltonian so in that sense you know
it's not frustrated because these these
local terms aren't fighting to
to reduce the energy so equivalently
there is an element in the intersection
of the kernels of all these projectors
and i said we need to lower down the
spectral gap of this hamiltonian
and actually quite a lot is known about
lower bounds on special gaps of uh
frustration-free hamiltonians
uh so notably there's this uh beautiful
theorem by canaba
which says that for one key translation
invariant frustration-free hamiltonians
the spectral gap on for the hamiltonian
n sites is lower bounded by this
quantity here
which involves the spectral gap of the
hamiltonian on three sites
so this is called a a finite size
criteria because you just
sort of need to check the the gap of the
hamiltonian on some small subsystem
and then that allows you to say
something about you know the special gap
of the hamiltonian for all
n um so you know
what you have to do is you have to go in
and check spectral gap on on three sites
and if it's larger than one half then
you're done
sort of show that it's gapped for all
for all n
um uh right so
just to kind of uh recap the steps we've
taken for this operator norm approach
amplification has told you know we're
considering uh
depth t random quantum circuits and
amplification tells us we don't actually
need to consider you know full depth of
random quantum circuits we just sort of
need to think about
a single layer of the circuit which by
which i actually meant
sort of an even layer and an odd layer
and then we reinterpreted this as a
spectral gap
basically using the detectability limit
to breakdown of these
of these gates into into some over the
gates roughly very roughly speaking
and then and then re-enter and then you
know basically reinterpreted that
that operator norm as the as the lower
bound on the spectral gap of a
hamiltonian
defined this way and then kanabu bounds
told us that we actually don't need to
consider the hamiltonian on n
on n qubits on n sites you just need to
consider the
uh the hamel the hamiltonian on on three
sites
okay so
what you can then go ahead and show is
that uh well first you can exactly
compute the
second moment opera the second moment
gap for uh
for uh for k again k equals two and n
equals three and you can see that it's
three
fifths and you go up here to the knobby
bound you look at
three-fifths and indeed it's it's larger
than one-half so you're done
through this series of steps you've
shown that random quantum circuits form
approximate two designs
um moreover you can use sort of the
almost orthogonality of the
ground states of this hamiltonian to
show that if you take the local
dimension q
to be larger than six times k squared
then the spectral gap on three sites for
any k
okay is lower bounded by three fourths
and three-fourths is larger than
one-half so we're done
and what those two things allow you to
conclude these lower bounds on the n
equals three gap allow you to conclude
is that random quantum circuits form
approximate two designs in this depth
and when the local dimension
is uh is at least this value you form
approximate designs
uh in this almost optimal depth so
before we had this behavior that was
linear in n and k
and now here we actually just have an
additional log q factor
uh so it's a it's a much better scaling
you know before we just had this kind of
unbounded
uh uh yeah this kind of uh
[Music]
this requirement of the local dimension
needed to be large in some way we
couldn't really control
but here we have a much more controlled
uh
local dimension but we have this
additional log q factor which is it's
pretty minor
in the design depth okay
so so this is nice we've uh sort of
shown that uh for
maybe possibly reasonable local
dimensions uh you get this optimal
behavior for
for random quantum circuits and um i'll
just briefly mention two other things
uh for near-term applications of random
quantum circuits this spectral gap
approach is actually nice because you
uh if you're just interested in maybe
the first few moments um
the constants involved are actually
important and you can just go ahead and
analytically or numerically compute
these spectral gaps
and they allow you to write down good
constants for the first few moments for
random circuits you might be interested
in
so uh yeah um that's nice for for maybe
near-term applications where you just
need the first few moments you don't
need these very high moments
but you do need good constants you can
also use
the spectral gap approach to improve the
design depth for non-local random
circuits
so everything i mentioned so far was for
for 1d circuits but
obviously these techniques work for
circus defined on other graphs
and uh yeah by showing some sort of
recursion relation on the spectral gaps
you can actually improve the
n and the k scaling for for non-local
random quantum circuits
using the spectral gap approach
okay so are there any questions about uh
spectral gaps or
or uh these either proof uh random
quantum circuits form designs
there was a comment in the qma saying it
was
confusing that t is both thickness and
time but i guess there's a reason for
that
uh sorry t is both what thickness and
time
but i guess that's uh oh i mean i just
uh
[Music]
i hope that wasn't confusing that was i
mean so t
t throughout this talk is is only the
circuit depth and i'm calling that time
so right right yeah just so just yeah
just to reiterate for anyone anyone
listening yet um what i mean by time
is is the circuit depth so that's that's
sort of a definition
yeah uh and yeah it's i mean
it's sort of maybe it depends on how you
orientate your circuits but i think
about the thickness of the circuits is
like n
and then the depth as as sort of as t
but
uh doesn't really matter okay
so um just in the last few minutes i'll
just mention
how some of these techniques can be
useful for understanding properties
uh which go beyond this notion of
pseudorandomness go beyond designs and
this is more
relevant for uh for
[Music]
different notions of quantum supremacy
so as you all know
recently google did an experiment where
they claimed to have demons
claimed to have done some tasks which
was intractable for a classical computer
and they actually ran some random
circuit on 53 qubits with a circuit
depth around 20
where their qubits were on some arranged
on a 2d geometry
and you know so they ran this random
circuit they measured in the
computational basis
and the classical distribution you get
over the upper probabilities they
claimed that sampling from that output
distribution
is uh is is not possible on a classical
computer
okay and i won't go into too many detail
details because bill gave a beautiful
overview
of uh of this subject in the previous
talk
but very roughly speaking we know that
exactly computing
these output probabilities is worst case
hard and what you need
to show to establish this this
conjecture is that uh
very roughly speaking some some
approximate average case hardness for
these output probabilities
so they're you know at a at a given
precision um
so one ingredient in arguments for
uh and the hardness arguments for random
circuit sampling is
something called anti-concentration and
anti-concentration basically says that
these output probabilities
uh so this distribution over measurement
outcomes are sufficiently spread out
okay and the fact that they're spread
out is uh
um is sort of some additional robustness
guarantee that that
says that the you know the signal is is
large relative to the noise
and more precisely what i mean by
anti-concentration is they'll say that
an ensemble of random quantum circuits
is anti-concentrated if
uh if the the square of these output
probabilities
is uh basically within some constant of
the r value
which is uh one over d squared or one
over q to the two n
okay so what we're able to do is uh we
kind of uh
applied these statmac techniques to
compute the depth at which random
quantum circuits anti-concentrate
and uh with uh alex gazelle and fernando
brandau what we showed is that for both
1d circuits and
random stickers to find out a complete
graph
for n quidits these random circuits
anti-concentrate when the circuits are
of size and log n
which roughly corresponds to log n depth
okay so uh you know this is uh
exponentially faster than the
than the uh the two design depth which
uh is a sufficient but not necessary
condition for anti-concentration
good so that was all i wanted to mention
it was just sort of
an overview of the different ideas in
many body physics and statistical
mechanics which allow you to
compute quantities of interest for
random circuits um
and i and i mentioned these sort of
results for for showing that random
circuits form unitary designs and also
you know you can apply similar
techniques to study anti-concentration
and there are a lot of open questions
that i still have about uh
showing you know that this linear design
growth holds for for any local dimension
q
and for exponentially long times um
it would also be nice to prove uh sort
of uh
that the design depth for non-local
random circuits so defined on the
complete graph
is uh n log n times sorry as log n times
k
um and they're you know i think these
stepmic approaches are very powerful and
people have generalized them
in all sorts of different ways but i
think there's a lot of room to study
you know kind of other generalizations
of random quantum circuits themselves
like adding conservation laws or
sort of adding some periodicity and time
um
but maybe that's all i'll mention for
now so thanks for listening and
let me know if you have any questions
good um uh so i guess one question on
maybe a basic question
uh so is it clear that like the data we
can't uh we
i can't hear you very clearly i think i
can barely hear but maybe if you speak
up a little bit
okay um i'll i'll try uh
is it clear so like how does the gate
set that you're
sampling over for the random quantum
churches in fact any of the parameters
or is it somehow clear that
it doesn't affect the practice yeah
that's a that's an excellent question
um and i i sort of intentionally glossed
over this but it's uh
uh right so at the beginning i said that
um uh my results will hold for more
general gait sets but
sort of in all the actual calculations i
did i used her random local gates so i
just
you know averaged over generic local
gigs um so for this first approach where
you use the
two norm there isn't a direct
generalization to
universal gate sets but in the second
approach there is
so i don't know what a good slide to
pause on is
just go here yeah so when you're
looking at this uh this operator norm um
uh yeah again you're computing you're
computing this quantity for uh
for our random local gates but it is
known that the
spectral gap for uh for
universal gate sets uh basically the the
operator norm
for the moment operator between power
random local gates and any universal
gate set is just some constant
so what that allows you to show is that
basically the spectral gap results need
to hold
with the same scaling in n and k
and you'll only change the the design
depth by a constant
so in the second approach uh it's it's
known that you can generalize to
universal gate sets there's some
additional restrictions like you need to
the gate set needs to involve inverses
and only you can have algebraic entries
in the gates but uh apart from those
minor caveats um
all these special gap approaches hold at
the same scaling in n and k you just
change the answer by a constant
and that constant will depend on the
gate set so obviously you can choose
gate sets where the constants will be
you know really bad and potentially you
know extremely large
and uh you know our random should
probably be the uh
you know correspond to a nearly optimal
constant
does that answer the question yeah um
yeah
uh a second question um so how does uh
so how do these notions of k designs and
like anti-concentration compared to like
generating a pseudo-random state yeah so
i i was maybe a little liberal with
uh i mean this is this is sort of how i
think about pseudorandom is but it's a
very it's a very strong
notion of pseudo-randomness and that um
so it is sort of like a quantum analog
of ky's independent distributions
but um you know these sets of random
circuits are
sort of k designs themselves uh are
maybe overkill and that they involve uh
you know sort of the cardinality of
these sets is
necessarily exponentially large they're
a lower bounds on the
on the number of elements you needed in
a design and if they're necessarily
large so i think for for uh you know
k designs are sufficient for a lot of uh
cryptographic notions of
of pseudorandomness but probably they're
overkill
but um you know they also they also
status you can also show that you know
designs are very strong in that they
satisfy you know additional strong
properties like you can't distinguish
some
some state acted on by a design
basically
in any way that's more efficient than
just undoing that circuit
so if it's okay yeah i just sort of
defined this as my notion of
pseudorandomness it's just a strong
notion of pseudorandomness
does that sort of answer the question
okay so uh it looks like there are no
more questions um
are there any uh closing remarks from
any of the organizers
otherwise um i guess we are
coming to the meetings coming to an end
for today
um so we'll see each other tomorrow